Remain silent
as you did when you spoke in June in Israel
beside the Israeli Prime Minister,
Natali Bennett.
Bennett. And did not say a word.
Not a word. After we've had two devastating reports
by Amnesty International,
by Human Rights Watch
of 70 years of ongoing crimes against humanity.
Ethnic cleansing, apartheid,
the siege of Gaza,
a 15 year long criminal action.
Uh, do we talk about,
investigate,
facing the war crimes of Israel? No.
Do we sanction Israel for these crimes
as we sanctioned Russia? No.
Instead, we continue to give them favoured trade status,
import huge amounts of gas from Israel,
deepen the relations and uh,
engage in considerable, uh,
military and defense trade
with the state that is doing this, uh,
to the Palestinian